the claim that marriage isn't scalable
is obviously ridiculous because marriage
has served as the Bedrock of human
society since time immemorial it has
already happened at the scale of
civilization for thousands of years now
the divorce lawyers come along and say
that you know this thing that society's
been doing forever turns out it doesn't
work unless you're the one in a million
it's it's ridiculous it's a ridiculous
claim now what about the failure rate of
marriages in our culture we've heard
fifty percent we've heard 75 percent we
just heard that they they fail at a rate
similar to the rate that people lose the
lottery which would mean higher than 99
a lot higher yet
these kinds of astronomical odds are not
based in anything but the Doom and Gloom
speculations of the people inventing
them